é
virtuelle. Ils avaient suivi
Obama lors de sa dernière
journée au pouvoir.
- Félix et Paul ont les yeux
tournés vers le ciel. Le studio
montréalais dispose de caméras
de réalité virtuelle qui filment
en 3D et à 360 degrés
à l'intérieur de la Station
spatiale internationale
et dans l'espace. Un projet de
près de 40 millions $.
Ils sont la seule entreprise
média partenaire officielle de
l'ISS et de la NASA.
FÉLIX LAJEUNESSE, cofondateur de
Félix et Paul Studios
- C'est une technologie
qui permet de faire vivre
une expérience autrement
inaccessible à des millions de
personnes, et de façon
totalement immersive.
- En 10 ans, le studio
montréalais de réalité virtuelle
s'est imposé comme un
des leaders mondiaux. Ils ont
collaboré avec les présidents
Clinton et Obama et réalisé
des projets partout
sur la planète et dans l'espace.
- Un projet mène à l'autre et
quand on essaie de faire des
choses complexes et ambitieuses
comme ça, bien c'est sûr que
d'avoir fait des projets
comme ça, ça rajoute
de la crédibilité.
- La mécène Phoebe Greenberg
a été la bougie d'allumage
de l'expansion internationale
du studio.
PHOEBE GREENBERG,
directrice de la création, PHI
- Le côté immersif, pour moi,
c'est vraiment le futur. Et les
nouveaux espaces commencent à
s'ouvrir pour inviter le public
à des expérience à l'axe
de la technologie, de la science
et de l'art.
- L'entreprise proposera
son projet le plus ambitieux
à ce jour, "L'INFINI",
une expérience multisensorielle
et interactive en réalité
virtuelle à bord de la Station
spatiale internationale,
coproduite avec PHI
et le prestigieux Studio Time.
JULIE TREMBLAY,
productrice, PHI Studio
- C'est tout à fait différent
d'une expérience de réalité
virtuelle standard qui se passe
vraiment juste dans le casque.
On est dans une expérience qu'on
appelle "free roaming", c'est-à-
dire que vous allez circuler
librement dans un grand espace,
vous allez circuler librement
à bord de la Station spatiale
internationale qui est
représentée grandeur réelle.
- Plusieurs astronautes,
dont David Saint-Jacques, ont
activement participé au projet
en filmant des séquences dans
la station. Réalité virtuelle
et exploration spatiale
font bon ménage.
MARIE BRASSARD, actrice,
conceptrice de "INFINI"
- On voulait justement aller
extraire, si je peux dire,
tout le caractère poétique,
esthétique, visuel,
philosophique qui est contenu
dans ces recherches
et ces explorations.
- Après sa présentation
à Montréal cet été, l'expérience
"L'INFINI" voyagera à travers
l'Amérique du Nord. Et s'ils ont
la tête dans les nuages,
Félix et Paul gardent quand même
bien les pieds sur terre.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canada, M